[Musique]
je vais maintenant prendre la direction
du loir et cher où les routes du
département sont le terrain de jeu du
champion andy cycliste raphaël beau
gilet le coureur déficients visuels
raphaël bougent ils effectuent une
partie son entraînement pour les jeux
paralympiques
ici au coeur de cour cheverny depuis son
domicile nous allons voir comment
justement ils préparent au quotidien son
entraînement c'est parti l'acadien ii
son cas et me voilà l'entrée du domicile
de raffaele bougies les uns qui se
prépare ici au quotidien au coeur de son
domicile
et aujourd'hui précisément sur sa
terrasse bonjour j'ai vu comment ça va
ça y est c'est parti là déjà ça y est
c'est parti pour un petit échauffement
après pour une petite sortie sur route
avec un pilote d'entraînement mais c'est
ce que vous faites seul tous les jours
alors pratiquement tous les jours oui
j'ai eu des séances de vélo spécifique
sur cet appareil
et de temps en temps ça arrive d'avoir
des sorties que signifier avec mon
tandem et sinon
on se rejoint pratiquement tous les
week-ends ou en stage avec mon pilote de
course françois pervis qui est
sprinteurs sept fois champion du monde
et du coup maintenant qui s'est donné
comme objectif en fin de carrière de le
piloter conte et chercher une médaille
aux jeux paralympiques de toute chose
alors justement quel planning quelles
plantes travail vous avez mis en place
pour tenter de rentrer ici en france
avec une médaille paralympique
on essaye de s'entraîner le maximum
possible leur ensemble parce que
forcément il ya des deux des
automatismes à avoir et quand vous êtes
ensemble sur le tandem comment vous
communiquer tous les deux en fait il
faut éviter de communiquer en se parlant
parce que du coup cédé aux dires de
l'énergie dépensés pour rien des petits
dixièmes qu'il faut gratter
donc on communique avant et après les
efforts on analyse avec des analyses
vidéo quand vous êtes finalement dans
cette préparation est ce que il ya
également évidemment la psychologie qui
rentre en compte
bah ça arrange beaucoup rencontre parce
que nous on fait des entraînements super
intense
ça fait très mal de partout mais
vraiment tout tout tout le corps ça
brûle
dans quel état d'esprit êtes-vous en ce
moment avant les jeux paralympiques on
est motivés à fond ça approche très vite
pleins on est dans une période
d'entraînement qui est assez dur mais
c'est normal
moi perso j'ai hâte après j'ai pas je
pense forcément de pression alors
aujourd'hui vous êtes là pendant
plusieurs dizaines de minutes sur ce
vélo et après en fait vous allez prendre
la route pour un entraînement quotidien
oui voilà c'est ça aujourd'hui j'ai une
sortie sur route dans 1h30 2h à faire
donc j'ai un pilote d'entraînement
grégory qui m'accompagne souvent
dès dès qu'il est disponible aussi alors
justement puisque vous évoquez grégory
tout à l'heure il vient juste d'arriver
il est derrière la barrière bonjour gros
merci d'être avec nous sur france 3
centre val de loire
finalement vous vous souvenez tous les
deux oui voilà on s'encourage ai dit
allez on continue puisque versa et puis
c'est une première en fait pour vous
d'accompagner quelqu'un qui va comme ça
en fait partir pour une olympiade hausse
est tout à fait une première - voilà
j'ai fait du rugby j'ai fait de la tis
un nouveau défi et
ouais c'est ce que j'aime et bien donc
on vous laisse le temps évidemment
d'assister à l'entraînement 2 rafael
c'est ça et moi de mon côté bien je vais
continuer mon voyage dans la région
direction blois
[Musique]